le collier des toiles de monsieur
balding grâce est avant tout un collier
de compte si vous aimez les contes
populaires lisez ce livre car il en
contient d'admirables ce sont des contes
d'ailleurs qui nous viennent de l'inde
et vous le savez peut-être
l'inde est la mère des comptes possède
d'admirables recueille l'un de ses
recueils a été traduit en anglais et il
comporte dix volumes mais surtout il ya
un recueil de contes très célèbre en
inde qui savaient le punch atatra
c'est un recueil qui datent environs du
1er siècle avant notre ère il fut
traduit pour la première fois au 6e
siècle empalé vie et puis traduit
ensuite en arabe et en syrien et ensuite
traduit en latin en grec et en slavon
puis traduit enfin en italien et en
français et au xviie siècle un français
lui c'est con du punch atatra ses
comptes qui concerne d'ailleurs des
animaux ce français s'en inspira il
s'appelle jean de la fontaine
les comptes de ce volume les comptes
réunis par monsieur baldé ndinga sont
toujours très simple il s'agit d'arbres
de rivières de montagne saint homme
d'exemples de piété ou de tendresse
mais rapidement on oublie le sujet le
sujet lui-même disparaît il semble que
le sujet fasse partie de l'illusion de
ce que les hindous appelle la maia est
que cette maya se dissipe pour nous
laisser une leçon leçon de sagesse ou
bien un précepte moral prenons un
exemple une histoire raconte ceci il y
avait une tigresse qui avait un petit
essai tigresse but poursuivi par les
chasseurs qu'ils à miramont le petit
heureusement se sauva il erra dans la
jungle
ils mourraient de faim et alors il fut
recueilli par des chaires les chèvres
sûrs pitié de lui
le prix est avec lui
et ma foi le petit tigre de 20 tout
comme une chèvre il brouter de l'herbe
et il bel est évidemment d'être
végétarien cela ne lui réussissait pas
trop il était maire mais enfin les
choses aller pour le mieux et les petits
tics faisait preuve d'un caractère très
doux très conciliante réchappant un jour
le troupeau de chèvres fut attaqué par
un grand tigre est naturellement toutes
les chèvres se débandent r100 sauvé sauf
évidemment parmi le troupeau quelqu'un
resta sur place et c'était justement le
petit tigre il n'avait pas de raison de
s'en aller devant le gros tigres il
continua de brouter et de bêler ce que
voyant le cantique se fâche à lui dit
mais comment toi un petit hic tu te
conduis comme une chef qu'est ce que tu
fais là tu mange de l'herbe tube elle
l'autre lui répondit mais je suis une
chef voyons dit le grand tigre vient
avec moi et ils le conduisit vers une
mare il le fils penché au dessus de la
main il lui dit regarde tu vas bien tu
as le têt semblable à la mienne qui me
ressemble tu es un tig allons viens avec
moi dans ma tanière le grand titre
emmène le petit tigre et dans la tanière
et lui dit tu vois par terre il y a des
eaux
il y à de la viande mange le pauvre
petit hic qui était végétarien fit
d'abord la grimace le dégoûte un peu il
goûta et puis il coûtait une seconde
fois il trouva ça assez bon la chair ils
en mangent davantage bientôt payant
mangeas beaucoup et puis il commença de
s'étirer baiia comme s'ils se réveillait
d'un très long sommeil
il poussa alors son premier rugissement
le grand tigre fut satisfait quand on a
le petit tigre dans la jungle avec lui
c'est une histoire morale elle ne paraît
pas sans doute moral et pourtant elle
l'est
car au fond que veut nous dire la
tradition à travers cette simple
histoire
elle va nous dire tout bonnement que une
chèvre est une chèvre un tigre est un
tigre c'est à dire qu'il faut être ce
que l'on est et ne pas essayer de
ressembler à ce que l'on n'est pas c'est
une belle leçon d'ailleurs seulement
voilà le compte ne nous dit pas comment
faire pour être ce que l'on est
c'est très difficile ça il est vrai
c'est une autre histoire est une
histoire qui n'est pas seulement
indienne
[Musique]